well nevadans lined up today in hopes of
winning it big the california lottery is
a powerball jackpot worth 640 million
the mega millions jackpot is worth 750
million
madison kimbrough is live in prim with
the lotto store that closed at five but
i'm sure people are still in line right
madison
yeah so as you can see behind me people
are still in line and while the line
isn't massive like it was
earlier i'm telling you the line was
extremely long to try
to get a ticket for this massive
powerball drawing now take a look at the
video that we shot earlier
where you can see that people are out
and about tonight's big powerball
drawing is for 640
million dollars and the mega millions
jackpot is for 750 million
most of the people i spoke to were from
las vegas and say this amount of money
is too good
not to play even with the long line
being
so long it's a ridiculous amount of
money
it's unreasonable amount of money and so
why not give a shot
you know trying to test my luck you know
i just got unemployed recently so
i need this money you know you hear
about the opportunity of winning some
money that can change your whole family
whole generation life
it's like hey what do you got to lose it
don't cost very much money and
a little trip from out of town to here
this and that get a ticket get something
to eat and who knows
yeah while at one point the line wrapped
around the parking lot mall here in prim
everyone seems to be in high spirits
hoping they have the winning ticket
and happy to report that the majority of
people in line were wearing
face coverings so as we mentioned before
the lotto store closed just
minutes ago and the drawing for the mega
millions jackpot
is tonight you can see the people in
line now something to clarify a reminder
for people
that if you play and you are a winner in
the state of california
you cannot remain anonymous reporting
live madison kimbrough
8 news now that's when people start
coming out of the woodwork there in
california